[Musique]
bienvenue dans le camp expérimental de
roald dernier seuls les meilleurs seront
retenus
intégrer la plus haute caste
alphanumériques
vous allez être soumis à une série de
tests physiques et psychologiques de
haute intensité
un émetteur vous sera implanté afin de
vous localiser à tout moment
[Musique]
nous avons repéré un groupe de
clandestins aux dégâts ils ont quitté
leur zone de confinement prestations
demandées
j'étais venu avec elle tu enfreint la
loi
pas un mot non par la personne ce que tu
éprouves est interdite ils vont vous
traquez cachant d'où viens avec moi mais
où veux tu aller dans un endroit où nous
serons libres m cette fille est une aux
médias une heure la loi et toi aussi
maintenant il va
[Musique]
ils n'auront aucune pitié
on trouvera un moyen de s'enfuir avec
var dans le monde que nous avons bâti
personne ne peut s'enfuir et le
nightfire est notre unique chance
d'entrer en contact avec eux les vols
cren exploite une énergie qui est 1000
fois supérieur à tout ce que vous pouvez
imaginer
et s'il nous aide à comprendre ce que
c'est peut-être qu'on pouvoir arriver à
sauver notre planète à sauver une erreur
dans les codes chef dysfonctionnement
sur le thème
quand chez vous
[Musique]
quelqu'un est entré dans le système je
ne peux pas trouver les codes du
programme capital risque on a un
problème
ces dysfonctionnements ne font que
retarder notre commence qu'est-ce qui va
pas quelque chose a pris le contrôle
[Musique]
une entité l'essai de saboter sa mission
il y avait quelque chose
la barre
ils sont certes devait s'ouvrir
et
ne reviendra pas sans avoir établi un
contact
côtoyer parce qu'ils sont
selon boris qu'ailleurs
il ne veut pas qu'on effectue ces
fusions
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
you are tu peux te tuer
oh
[Musique]
des quotas
il resta
émana a brûlé
et attendre
[Musique]
ocs
vous êtes fan nous aussi
vous
oui
[Applaudissements]
mua
les marcheurs
tout est fait regarder
dont les assiettes tant appris qu'on
dise oh je bougeais pas toujours
pourquoi tu as pris tout ça alors
parce que c'est gratos le all inclusive
c'est de voir la maman cousin conseils
de vieil pro premier au buffet premiers
transats pour les boissons
on mélange mais moi de zombies coco brin
inquiet râle quand deux tiers d'eau ok
alors quatre bras olindo ville
il faut mettre le paquet sur les
animations je ne veux pas voir un mot
qui s'ennuient un mot qui s'éclate c'est
un nombre qui va bien et un moment qui
va bien c'est un bon mot qui revenait du
matin on se serait pas déjà croisé
quelque part tous les jeunes peut-être
non
[Musique]
je le dis comme ça en passant je suis
retraité éleveurs manquent libre est
libre bon à savoir traverser
j'ai perdu mon baluchon que c'est la
cata son baluchon servat le chou un
ballon chaud en forme de ballon
quatre panneaux chez une pendule pour
trois maillots et de tisha ma mère dans
le baluchon brno
tam est elle morte un poil au bon moment
non mais c'est vrai tu me fais quoi là
jeff pana clock
elle est d'accord c'est le grand
carnaval
[Musique]